hey everyone welcome back to the chicas
I'm Chu so today we're going to look at
what are the hallmarks of aging so
firstly what actually is aging so aging
is the progressive deterioration of an
organism made of time pretty much
characterized by the accumulation of
damage and the loss of function to
understand the aging process better
aging has been characterized in two
different hallmarks that I will
introduce in this video so so far there
have been nine different hallmarks of
aging that have been proposed the first
four commands are primary causes of
Aging the first of these is DNA or
genetic instability so DNA gets damaged
and mutated every single day whilst the
cell has ways of dealing with this
damage it is inevitable that over time
damage will accumulate the problem is
damage can affect gene expression
patterns and they can also directly
affect the gene themselves this can
result in loss of cellular function
second a nihilist is loss of previous
cases so preety a stasis includes
processes that control the formation of
correctly folded proteins because
correctly folded proteins equals
functional happy protein next up is
telomere attrition so telomeres are
often explained as being the shear caps
on chromosomes that remain the integrity
of the chromosome however over time the
telomeres shorten and so this integrity
gets lost the last primary cause of
aging is epigenetic changes now there is
just so much to say about epigenetic
changes that I cannot explain it all
here but the key thing is is that there
seems to be changes in the epigenetic
mark as you age this can then alter the
gene expression patterns and affect the
stability of genome so now let's look at
the antagonistic remarks so these are
the hallmarks that kind of respond to
the damage caused so first up is the
deregulation of nutrient signaling so
nutrient signaling describes the
responses
to food intake and how that I've elicits
growth pathways or it and promotes
stress resistance pathways so again this
is a really complex topic and it
enforced the interactions between
different growth factors hormones and
intracellular components and how they
get deregulated during high nutrient
signaling next up is mitochondrial
dysfunction so mitochondria are
essential for Arabic respiration which
enables energy production in the cell
however over time this process becomes
less efficient therefore the ATP the
energy required for many different
processes in the cell also become
deficient in addition leakiness in their
spirit or train can generate free
radicals that condemn as proteins and
lipids in the cell as well the last
antagonistic hallmark is cellular
senescence so cellular senescence can be
defined as a cell state whereby the cell
no longer divides it stops replicating
in addition senescence cells have a
secretory phenotype that can affect the
surrounding cells as well and so aging
has been shown to correlate with an
increase in the number of senescence
cells so now let's look at the
integrator for marks which are
effectively the outputs of the result of
the first two categories and are
ultimately responsible for the
functional decline that has seen an
Asian so the first of these is altered
intercellular communication in aging
this is characterized by an altered
extracellular environment and an
increase in inflammation and lastly in
aging there is an Associated loss of
stem cells so stem cells are cells
that's keep on replicating another
therefore regeneration and repair of
tissues therefore if they get lost over
time you are less able to repair damage
in the body which can lead to functional
decline
so that was a bit of a whizz through the
different call marks of a Jim if you
want to find out more information I
highly recommend reading the review
article but I'm going to go into more
detail probably in the next few videos
of the different hallmarks